we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors steadymd lets you maintain a
meaningful long-lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit
steadymd.com pacman to get started
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman the day is finally here
today is the end
of the donald trump era it is the start
of the presidency
of joe biden who will be or has already
been sworn in by the time you listen to
today's show by the time you watch this
clip
it has felt like so long and at the same
time it feels like just yesterday that i
was watching those numbers come in from
florida
at 7 25 pm eastern time in november of
2016 and thinking this isn't looking
quite so good for hillary clinton
but we've talked about all that and
today is the day where trump out
biden in and finally
the beginning of getting beyond the
global historic
nightmare that has been the trump
administration but donald trump did not
leave quietly yes he was quiet on
twitter because he was suspended
yes we didn't see any live uh press
conference or speech from donald trump
uh in the lead-up to his final days but
trump was never going to leave totally
quietly and he delivered yesterday a
deranged and meandering screed
of a speech we will look only at a few
clips today we are all
so glad to be getting beyond this but
it's important to know what were the
last utterances
to slip from trump's mouth the theme
yesterday in this
pre-recorded speech the theme was trump
taking credit for really
anything that he could even just general
delusions of grandeur
like this one with the support and
prayers of the american people
we achieved more than anyone thought
possible
nobody thought we could even come close
of course
whatever achievements you think did take
place
during this trump administration
historically will be outweighed
dramatically by the massive overwhelming
failures of the administration
on everything in particular on covid
on global relations on climate and i
could go on and as i've said before
had trump properly handled the virus
response
it would be trump being sworn in for
four more years today
not joe biden we saw it happen in other
countries
and that was trump's undoing he couldn't
control
that he had to deal with the virus
nobody could but
proper handling of the virus did lead to
re-elections for leaders that handled it
correctly
trump wildly and incorrectly claiming
that
now the world respects us and warns that
we should avoid losing the respect
he believes or claims to have secured
for the united states
completely delusional and we know we
know that for a fact take a look
the world respects us again please
don't lose that respect
so this has been widely studied we don't
have to
speculate we don't have to guess we
don't need
conjecture respect for the united states
around the world
absolutely in the toilet you know those
toilets trump says he you know would
have to flush 10 or 15 times
if joe biden's environmental regulations
get in well
that's where the global reputation is
for the united states in the toilet
and the challenge will actually be the
opposite of what donald trump says it
will be
can joe biden restore respect for the
united states with trump gone
what countries are willing to say okay
let's let's re-establish mutual trust
and respect
after trump is gone i think many
countries will be willing to do that
uh because it matters that uh we
re-establish those alliances it matters
for them as much as it matters for us
but no trump
with with opposite opposite day speech
the respect was lost
under trump trump also interestingly
saying he deliberately chose the tough
battles rather than taking the easy path
he sort of framed
during this pre-recorded uh speech that
was released yesterday
he said you know par part of what made
his administ his presidency tough was he
chose to do the tough things sort of uh
an illusion in some sense to john f
kennedy but failing miserably to make
any kind of analogy as president my top
priority
my constant concern has always been the
best interests of american workers and
american families
i did not seek the easiest course by far
it was actually the most i took on the
tough battles
the hardest fights the most difficult
choices
because that's what you elected me to do
your needs were my first and last
unyielding focus
this i hope will be our greatest legacy
this one is interesting because in a way
it's sort of a positive moment he's not
attacking anyone necessarily not
directly anyway
but it's also very disconnected from
reality he actually chose
easy things and messed them up and he
also messed up things
that every president has to deal with
and he also messed up things that every
world leader was presented with and
dealt with better than trump coronavirus
of course being
at the top of that list trump did say
and i think this is the closest
i've ever heard trump be to conciliatory
in any way
trump said he is praying for the success
of the next administration but there's a
little weird tweak he adds in there that
i want to talk about
this week we inaugurate a new
administration
and pray for its success in keeping
america safe
and prosperous we extend our best wishes
and we also want them to have luck a
very
important word trump has to add
something
snarky or weird and it's trump
mentioning
luck and this is a reference to
trump seeing himself as having had bad
luck that he had to deal with the
coronavirus pandemic
but more importantly trump didn't even
mention joe biden in this 20-minute
speech
trump mentions the next administration
as he did in these vague terms
about eight to ten days ago but he never
says joe biden and he didn't say it
today in another a final screed that we
will get to
and it is another one of these signals
about the petulant
child that is donald trump now it is
true
that without trump's mishandling of the
pandemic he would have been reelected i
talked about that moments ago
but trump handling the pandemic well
is not a question of luck it's just a
question of who was determined to do it
and who was capable of doing it as we
saw many world leaders do
the bad luck was actually for us the bad
luck was for the world
that we were so unlucky that it was
trump in power
when the global hundred year pandemic
hit just about anyone else including
just you know a high school science
teacher any like
anybody who would have just said oh this
is a situation where we need experts
let's defer to them from day one
would have worked out better than having
trump in power that's bad luck for us it
wasn't trump's bad luck
uh trump wrapping up the end of this uh
pre-recorded speech
by taking a page out of kimberly
guilfoyle's playbook
remember from the republican national
convention the best
is yet to come you remember that here's
trump
using that phrase i go from this
majestic
place with a loyal and joyful heart
and optimistic spirit and a supreme
confidence that
for our country and for our children
the best is yet to come thank you
and farewell god bless you god bless
the united states of america so another
lame
speech to cap off a lame failed
presidency that we are
thrilled to see finally over and notice
that in this entire speech trump didn't
mention joe biden as i said earlier
he completely glossed over 400 000
coronavirus deaths
although he mentioned that this morning
he glosses over the pro-trump riots that
he inspired at the capitol two weeks ago
and the
militarized state of the city as trump
leaves thanks to him and it is yet
another pathetic joke now
one little extra goodbye on his way out
trump revoked the executive order that
banned administration officials from
becoming lobbyists within five years of
leaving government
drain the swamp right my friends and
that's something that really should be
codified into law rather than left up to
administrations
uh we will be covering the inauguration
but first trump's final
weird sort of rally-like goodbye
happened this morning let's talk about
that next
donald trump uh did not go to joe
biden's inauguration
breaking with tradition the first
president
in i believe 152 years not to go to
their replacements inauguration trump
left he went to
florida early this morning but on his
way out
he did leave the white house and take
the marine one helicopter to andrews air
force base and before getting on air
force one for that final flight
delivered a five or seven minute speech
and
said even more things that make no sense
to a very deflated crowd
trump asking to be remembered if things
improve under biden
trump saying if things do get better in
the next few months it's because of me
please remember me you're gonna see
incredible numbers start coming in
if everything is sort of left alone be
careful
very complex be careful but you're going
to see some
incredible things happening and uh
remember us when you see these things
happening if you would
remember us because uh i'm looking
at uh i'm looking at elements of our
economy that are set to be
a rocket ship up it's a rocket ship up
very powerful elements
of the economy that he's looking at as
he says there
how long overdue is it for this
nightmare to be over uh this morning's
speech really reminded me of that
trump's still using the term china virus
another aspect of how this morning
speech was almost the same as the
campaign speeches trump had been giving
china virus it's a horrible thing that
was
put onto the world we all know where it
came from but it's a horrible horrible
thing
so be very careful be very very careful
but
we want to pay uh great love great love
to all of the people that have suffered
including families who have suffered so
gravely
uh and then i mean listen that's really
the first time i've heard trump sincere
sort of sincerely mention the people who
have actually suffered from the virus
trump for good measure he can't get away
from these things
again claiming the 1918 flu started in
1917
we don't know why he's been saying this
for a year but he said it again
put it in a position like it's never
been before despite the worst plague to
hit since i guess you'd say
1917 over a hundred years ago
and it is a goodbye for now as donald
trump
pledges to be back and says
have a nice life to the crowd sort of
the send-off we would expect from the
guy who never really cared about his
supporters as people he cared for
about them only in so far as it was
useful to his political goals
the things that we've done have been
just incredible
and i couldn't have done them done it
without you so just
a goodbye we love you
we will be back in some form and
again uh i wanted just in living i want
to thank our vice president mike pence
and karen
i want to thank congress because we
really worked well with congress
at least certain elements of congress
but we really did we've gotten so much
done that nobody thought would be
possible but i do want to thank congress
and i want to thank all of the great
people of washington dc
all of the people that we worked with to
put this miracle together
so have a good life we will see you soon
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much
[Music]
so there it is have a nice life and you
hear ymca
cranking up there a surreal and bizarre
moment
and with that donald trump is done
flying off
into the sunrise not into the sunset it
was early this morning flying off to
mar-a-lago in palm beach florida
before joe biden's inauguration alluding
to
we don't know if it's a 2024 run
although i don't expect that
we don't know if it's alluding to there
were rumors of trump starting a new
party to be different than the
republican party
rumors of many different things we just
don't know
but hours before leaving office donald
trump issuing 143 pardons and i do want
to talk about that
just hours before flying off to palm
beach florida and skipping the
inauguration
donald trump issued his final list of
pardons
and he is not on the list and his
children are not on the list and we will
talk a little bit about why
momentarily a lot of speculation about
that
but the list does include a variety of
individuals 143 pardons maybe most
prominently steve bannon
former white house chief strategist and
close adviser to donald trump
pardoned now the insane there's nothing
more trumpy than the following
steve bannon was arrested for felony
fraud
for defrauding build the wall donors
these were pro-trump donors who wanted
to build the wall
they donated to this hey give us money
and we'll build it
and it was a total scam trump pardoned
the guy who scammed trump's own
supporters and if you needed any more
proof
that trump never cared about his
supporters beyond how they were useful
to him politically
it is the pardon of steve bannon how
many times does trump need to betray
his own supporters before they realized
trump never cared about them to begin
with
also uh pardoned eliot broidy former
republican finance
chair kwame kilpatrick former democratic
mayor of detroit
randy duke cunningham a former
republican congressman rick renzi former
republican congressman robin hayes
former republican congressman two
rappers lil
wayne and kodak black
notably missing from the list are
pardons for his
family and pardons for himself and this
apparently
was the culmination of a pretty dramatic
couple of days where on saturday evening
this is a report
from cnn um donald trump
was warned he had a long meeting with
his advisors on saturday night
and at that point he still was leaning
towards pardoning in advance
his children his son-in-law maybe rudy
giuliani and possibly even himself
and he was told don't do it he was told
if you pardon them and even yourself
you will be placing yourself in a
legally perilous position
it will convey the appearance of guilt
it will potentially make you
more vulnerable to reprisals and indeed
donald trump um acquiesced to that
and decided not to pardon his children
and not to pardon himself some of these
warnings came from white house counsel
pat chipoloni as well as another
attorney
eric hershman who was involved in
defending trump in his first impeachment
trial and they all said to trump do not
pardon yourself
do not pardon your family do not pardon
uh
any anybody in a prospective manner
unless you will list specific crimes
and that was the concern a blanket
preemptive pardon
had trump said well i pardon ivanka
in advance for campaign finance crimes
as an example
this lawyer said that would be better
but it also is pointing a finger at
specific crimes you believe
maybe they would be charged with and in
the end trump deciding
i'm not going to pardon any of them and
even after
saturday trump kept bringing this up
even after people around trump thought
it's done he's not going to pardon his
kids or himself
trump kept bringing it up bringing it up
bringing it up and the final
meeting reportedly where trump finally
was convinced okay i'm not going to do
it
took place on a saturday evening and
it's interesting as a general thing
because trump has often ignored advice
given
advice given to him in fact trump
ignoring advice given to him is
responsible for much of the trouble
that he got into during his presidency
and there's a reason why defense
attorneys
say even if you think you had nothing to
do with the crime it's better not to
answer questions to law enforcement
just call a lawyer and say you don't
want to say anything
there's a reason why that's the case and
much of donald trump's trouble if we
look back at his
beleaguered four years much of that
trouble caused by trump choosing to
speak rather than not by trump trump
choosing to act
rather than doing nothing and just
waiting for things to happen without his
involvement
and i don't know if there's a lesson
here i mean the real lesson should be
how on earth how how can we prevent
75 million people from being bamboozled
by this guy and thinking it's a good
idea to elect him
that's really the lesson that hopefully
we would learn and and and somehow
prevent in the future
uh i don't know if that's the case i
don't know if that has been learned but
the pardon list the final pardon list is
out so this is the end of the trump
era and the beginning of the biden era
tomorrow we will have the timing of
today made it difficult to have
inauguration coverage today
on the show we'll be covering it live
and maybe you're with us right now maybe
you watched it earlier with us
tomorrow we will have coverage of the
biden inaugural the initial speech
scheduled to have a press briefing
already
from trump's biden's incoming press
secretary jen sackey tonight
and then joe biden already scheduled
today to sign a bunch of executive
orders which you can be sure
we will be uh looking at tomorrow and
seeing if joe biden sticks to his
promises so quick break
let me know your thoughts about what's
go excuse me what's going on
on twitter where you can find me at d
pacman
and then a bunch of final stories to tie
up some loose ends coming up here
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and
after that your doctor is available to
you anytime by text
phone or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy and anything they can't do
online
they'll quickly set you up with an
in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs they have a special
offer only for my audience you'll get 50
percent off your first
month but only until january 31st so
make sure to sign up soon
click the link right underneath this
video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the number one place to get memberships
during the joe
biden era is of course
grab a membership get instant access to
the bonus show the commercial free audio
feed the commercial free video feed
all of that great stuff plus the feeling
of knowing you are
supporting an alternative to homogeneous
corporate media
joinpakman.com is the place to do it and
what a day to do it by the way um there
are
increasing discussions as we transition
from donald trump to joe biden about the
possibility
of joe biden pardoning donald trump
and we have heard from folks on the
right
we've heard even from some folks on the
left we've heard from
national security figures and others
maybe
joe biden should do for the country
what gerald ford did for the country
to richard nixon which is to pardon
nixon
the way that joe biden could pardon
donald trump
i think that this is a disastrous idea
and under no circumstances whatsoever
should joe biden pardon donald trump
first of all
merely on the facts trump has been way
worse than nixon
much more weaponized much more dangerous
to the united states
uh in in terms of what the u.s
is supposed to be as the democracy
and everything else that we believed up
at least
until donald trump was elected the u.s
was supposed to be
secondly the mere idea
that you would be able to unite with
these
absolutely delusional trumpists if joe
biden were to pardon donald trump
is a complete and total fantasy and so
when i hear anecdotally people across
the political spectrum
to differing degrees saying i don't know
maybe joe biden should look at pardoning
donald trump
absolutely not let's look at some of the
arguments
one argument is if biden pardons trump
it prevents trump from pardoning himself
which would be terrible but the timing
doesn't make any sense by the time
biden can do the pardoning trump can no
longer do it maybe the idea was
if biden sends a signal that he'll
pardon trump then maybe trump would
doesn't make any sense it makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever
it wouldn't get a single trumpist to
cooperate with the biden administration
it just will never happen
and if you've been paying attention the
last four years how could you possibly
think
that there's anything joe biden could do
that would get
a significant portion of trump is to
cooperate with the biden administration
i heard
former fbi director james comey for
example suggesting a pardon quote
as part of healing the country
and getting us to a place where we can
focus on things that are going to matter
over the next four years give me a break
jim
the trump wing of the republican party
is not going to heal they're not going
to participate in any healing at least
that's for sure
if joe biden were to pardon donald trump
it wouldn't make any difference
it will become it actually may be worse
it may become
part of the conspiracy theories they
will say well biden was
forced to do it as part of a deal
to protect hunter or some kind of
harebrained thing it won't work it's
it's nuts
to think that it would another reason
not to pardon donald trump
is that we need trump and his family to
be as
busy as possible dealing with civil
lawsuits
investigations and possible charges that
will come
to the trump organization to the trump
campaign and maybe even to trump and his
family members as well
because that may actually be what
prevents donald trump from running again
in 2024
let's not give trump any escape from
years of being stuck in a legal hell
hole which is likely where he's going to
end up now
in contrast to richard nixon
richard nixon had not been impeached
richard nixon resigned
to avoid impeachment after he lost the
support of the republican party
republicans went to richard nixon and
said it's over
we will have to convict you in an
impeachment if you don't resign and
nixon resigned
contrast that which with what happened
with trump trump has been impeached
twice
and republicans have basically stayed
with trump
okay mitt romney on one count in the
first impeachment voted to convict
so far we don't know when the second
impeachment trial of trump will be
but so far 10 republican members of the
house
voted to impeach trump last week but the
vast majority of republican voters are
still with donald trump
with nixon there was actually a reason
to say listen
republicans came together with democrats
they all went to nixon
and they said you've got to go we will
impeach if you don't go
there is at least more of an arguable
defense of pardoning nixon
the trump fiasco is the opposite trump
has refused to even consider
that he did anything wrong never mind
resignation republicans
stood by trump during impeachment number
one despite
obvious signs that trump must go and he
was descending further and further into
the authoritarianism that we saw around
the november 2020 election
so by pardoning trump you are in effect
also excusing the behavior of the
republican party
in standing by him and in spreading
disinformation
so the situation is drastically
different and then lastly
although trump and the republican party
claim to be the party of law and order
they're not we saw trump's scofflaw
nature
his entire presidency we saw the january
6th trump riots
we know that they are the furthest thing
from the party of law and order for joe
biden to pardon trump
would be to effectively say you are now
immune
from law breaking joe biden should be
the president of law and order
which means he can't pardon donald trump
but on the other hand
it should be joe biden will not be
involved in any trump investigation
joe biden should simply say to his
justice department
to whoever i will have nothing to do
with investigations into the former
president
i won't ask you to investigate and i
will not ask you
not to work through the evidence work
through allegations and do what you need
to do
that's law and order what trump has done
is not law and order
now is there any reason to think joe
biden plans to pardon donald trump there
is not
joe biden has previously said he would
not pardon trump we know lately
more and more people have been saying
biden should pardon trump
but hopefully as far as we know right
now joe biden has not changed his mind
on that
and i hope that he does not if you
disagree with me let me know
i want to hear from you um as if we need
any last disastrous revelations about
the trump administration as it
ends uh we found out now that
the trump administration through its
coronavirus stimulus
actually gave 850 000
listen to this to anti-vaccine
groups while the trump administration
publicly claimed to be pushing
vaccination
the trump administration gave
anti-vaccine
groups cash i guess because they were
affected by the pandemic
it's absolutely and completely insane
five prominent anti-vaccine
organizations
known to spread misleading
disinformation about the virus and
vaccines
received more than eight hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
from the paycheck protection program
of course making us ask why
are they giving money to groups that
oppose
their stated agenda the stated agenda of
the trump administration
is vaccines are good and people should
get them
and yet they gave money to groups saying
all sorts of dishonest and deceptive
things about the virus and about
vaccines the groups are
the national vaccine information center
should be called the disinformation
center
mercola health resources the informed
consent action network the chil
children's health defense and the 10
penny integrative medical center
okay these are groups that to different
degrees
are anti-vaccine and spread anti-vaccine
disinformation some of these groups have
facebook pages
that have been suspended temporarily or
permanently
because they spread disinformation some
of these groups aren't allowed
to buy facebook ads because they spread
disinformation
and for some reason the trump
administration
through its ppp program gave them money
who could have guessed that there would
be abuse
when a program ppp that was supposed to
have oversight just doesn't
oh right that's actually completely
predictable and one of the stories
of the trump administration to think
about in the future
will be trump placating and pandering to
many lunatic fringes
anti-vaxx is just one of them one of the
really important things to understand
and over the last four years i i've
yelled at anyone who will listen to me
about it
we've done interviews about
conspiratorial thinking we've done
interviews about how these
types of thinking develop and the
overlaps between
people prone to what we call bottomless
skepticism skepticism is good
bottomless skepticism that can never be
satisfied that anything is as some
others say
is not healthy and what we found out is
that
not only are many trump followers prone
to conspiratorial thinking
uh trump himself has placated and
pandered to many of these lunatic
fringes
anti-vaxx we saw that very early in uh
even during the transition period of
donald trump um
and we've seen trump placate all sorts
of other
lunatic fringes including those who
thought that there there were i mean
listen first of all
the the so-called virus skeptics who for
months said it's like the flu
that's a lunatic fringe um but also
people with really wacky ideas
about uh how elections work and what the
law is
around elections and and anyway we've
covered a lot of them over time
uh but one other thing i was thinking of
is you know donald trump said he
considers himself a wartime president he
says
coronavirus is a war he said it was
against the china virus
that's not what we call it but he
believes that he has been a wartime
president
if you give money to the anti-vaccine
group during war
isn't that treason i don't know
certainly something to think about and
uh i i hope
my hope is that if the joe biden
stimulus happens
i hope that the monitoring and the
regulation and the oversight
actually happens and this money to
anti-vaxx groups would be just one of
many things
that hopefully would be prevented we're
going to have more
including the inauguration of joe biden
on our instagram where you can find us
at david pakman show
find me on instagram david.patrick
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show i
want to talk a little bit about
the repercussions and and the fallout
including positive fallout from the
suspension of donald trump from
twitter now we can have a
reasonable debate about the suspension
of donald trump from twitter there's no
question that he did violate the terms
and conditions of twitter and he's been
violating them for years and if any
non-president were doing that
they would have been suspended from
twitter long ago at the same time the
counterpoint would be that there's value
in hearing from what world leaders say
and thus the suspension is in some way a
detriment
to um knowing what it is that our
leaders are feeling and saying and doing
or whatever the case may be i don't want
to focus on that in this particular
segment
because there have been a lot of
headlines floating around
that election misinformation has dropped
dramatically
since donald trump was banned from
twitter and of course
that's true it absolutely has online
misinformation about election fraud
is down 73 percent
after not only twitter but several
social media sites suspended donald
trump
uh about eight nine ten days ago this is
based on a report from
signal labs and when you look at this
if you believe that the sole cause of
the reduction of disinformation
is trump's suspension from these
platforms that is a big
uh endorsement of this as a policy that
if you identify
particularly important uh sort of nodes
of disinformation by getting rid of them
you stop the trickle down as it
effectively is
of disinformation trump with what were i
think 80 or something million followers
on twitter
would tweet disinformation and then
these kind of next level people like his
family and prominent journalists and
influencers would retweet and
signal boost the same bogus ideas and
then you would have lower level media
and voters and it continues and
continues and next thing you know
uh you know your great aunt who's not
even on twitter
is hearing about some of these ideas
sunday morning on fox business uh to
point to maria bartoromo as
as an example i think that the analysis
has to go a little bit
deeper though uh because when donald
trump was suspended from twitter and
from these other platforms
other things also went on that would
explain the dramatic reduction in
disinformation around the election
and we can't say it was merely
suspending trump for example
um about 70 000 q anon
associated accounts were purged from
twitter
at the same time it's not just trump
being gone
it's twitter buckling down on a lot of
these signal boosting accounts
sanctions on a parlor in so far
as apple and google said no more parlor
on our app stores
and amazon said we're not hosting parlor
anymore
that's also a factor in reducing the
spread of this election disinformation
the election was also certified and the
capital
got stormed and it created a completely
new
look at the circumstances for a lot of
people so
i just don't think we can point merely
to trump being suspended and saying
that's why election disinformation is
down 73 percent to say it's down 73
because trump was banned from twitter
seems like a stretch to me
to say it coincided along with these
other reasons
makes a lot of sense to me and part of
me hopes that this will help to
deprogram some
people who have fallen into fanaticism
but unfortunately
if you believe that it wasn't
disinformation in other words if you
hear me say
election disinformation is down 73
and your reaction is that wasn't
disinformation
the truth about the elections is down 73
because they're censoring it then the
fact that i'm reporting this will become
part of the conspiracy
and as i've said before it's very hard
to argue against folks who are committed
to those
uh narratives i will say one other thing
we've talked a lot about the importance
of deprogramming deprogramming trumpists
and deprogramming conspiracy theorists
and the like
on tomorrow's show we are going or maybe
on friday but i'm hoping it'll be
tomorrow
if we have time for it we are going to
do a deep dive
on a recent focus group that was done
with trump voters okay this it's it's
unbelievable
frank luntz did a focus group with 12
trumpists
after the january 6th riots and
everything about this focus group tells
us
what we need to know about the uphill
battle
of deprogramming trumpists and in
particular the role that right-wing
radical media has
on it being so difficult to deprogram
them so tomorrow or friday we're going
to do a deep dive into that
one of the most overrated lightweights
to take
a term from trump's vocabulary is former
south carolina governor and former trump
ambassador to the united nations
nikki haley nikki haley wasted no time
in appearing on farcical newsmax
hosted by by sean spicer yeah
that sean spicer trump's pathetic former
press secretary sean spicer
and she went on to talk to sean spicer
on newsmax
rehabilitating the same tired
predictable talking points that i've
been telling you for a year now
would instantly reappear when a democrat
is sworn into office and donald trump
leaves now a year ago we didn't even
know
which democrat it might be that replaces
donald trump
but it didn't matter no matter which
democrat
replaced trump they would go oh
dead in deficit we can't afford
this we can't afford that the far
left socialists are taking over we knew
what the playbook was going to be
and here is nikki haley playing her role
saying that joe biden's far-left foreign
policy
is going to be very dangerous listen to
her
answer after sean spicer manages to
cough
out this softball question you have this
new op-ed out
that you talk about the democrats going
leftward but i want to talk about this
in the context
of biden and his foreign policy
specifically
who he's appointed and who in the
policies that he's going to pursue
can you kind of talk about where you
think uh
the biden foreign policy and the biden
personnel picks are going to go
direction-wise i mean look i'm i'm not
going to lie i'm extremely concerned
about
um what's going on you've got iran
they're in the process of producing
nuclear weapons and here biden wants to
get back into the iran deal
she's very concerned by
notice the idiocy of what she says she
says
look iran is producing nuclear weapons
and biden wants back into the deal
don't let them trick you okay first of
all iran is resuming
resuming research into nuclear they're
not producing weapons yet but they could
but what she's saying is not true but
yes iran is resuming research
why is iran resuming research into
nuclear power and nuclear uh
energy which could be used for weapons
iran is doing that
because they abided by the nuclear deal
that barack obama struck with them
trump came into office and simply
canceled it without iran having done
anything wrong so of course as i told
you
the day trump did this that iran was
going to go back to nuclear research and
they did
the iran deal was the only thing keeping
iran from doing the nuclear research
and now nikki haley is already blaming
biden
for wanting to get back into the deal
which was actually working to stop iran
from developing
is this bad faith or is nikki that
ignorant i have a really hard time
believing that nikki haley
is this ignorant i assume that this is
just bad faith pandering
to a radical newsmax audience that
doesn't know any better
let's listen to a little bit more of
this when you look at his
picks for cabinet and otherwise i mean
from john kerry to susan rice
you you don't have to be you know that
much of a historian to know where this
is going and i think this is going to be
to the left of obama i think we need to
hold on to our wallet
and i think we need to stop with all of
the the finger pointing and that he said
she said and we've got to get to work
this is this is going to hurt and we
need to really be focused on where we're
going to go from here
isn't that just outrageous and pathetic
john
kerry and susan rice completely
uncontroversial milk toast
moderate democrats nothing radical about
john kerry and susan rice nothing
socialist about them
john kerry very smart more than well
qualified understands climate issues
these are the far left scary people now
john
kerry is far left now and then of course
she says
we've got to hold on to our wallets what
you might be wondering what is she
talking about
trump exploded the deficit more than any
recent president
more than obama more than bush clinton
had a surplus never mind
what is she talking about the stimulus
and infrastructure spending that biden
wants
is much needed it generates revenue by
creating jobs and putting money back
into the hands of small businesses so
i i hate that i'm right about this i
hate that i was right and many of you
were as well you emailed me and said
david
they're going back to debt and deficit
and all of this stuff they
aren't even waiting for joe biden to be
sworn in
to get back to the pathetic talking
points that we had a four-year break
from
the question is are the same
right-wingers
going to fall for these same talking
points again or has the ship
sailed remains to be seen but there is
going to be plenty of this
on fox news on oan and on newsmax
and it is going to take everything we
have
to take a group that has already they're
already so in need of deprogramming
and now you're going to see newsmax and
oan scale up and maybe you'll see fox
news do it as well to try to keep up
with them
it's going to be a very much uphill
battle and they are wasting no time
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is member
supported get the world
famous bonus show and commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
by signing up at joinpackman.com
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
it's really been an interesting four
years from sean hannity he went from
already prominent right wing
propagandist on fox news
really to a presidential insider i mean
a friend of donald trump's who
not so much recently but certainly
earlier on in his administration
hannity and trump often speaking on the
phone at night hannity was sometimes the
last person trump would speak to before
i i guess going to bed if that's
something donald trump does i don't know
he doesn't really seem
to do anything the way most of us do but
in any case
sean hannity had really become an
insider sometimes traveling on uh
trump's uh helicopter or on air force
one he would do these
sycophantic softball interviews of trump
he would do sycophantic interviews of
kaylee mcinanny and many others
well uh sean hannity's ratings have
absolutely collapsed
since the election and eric bullert has
some great reporting on this
fox has actually been touting the latest
ratings numbers
as a big win for sean hannity and a lot
of publications fell for it and they put
together headlines that make it seem
like everything's going great for
hannity fox for example running an
article
on december 16th called sean hannity
tucker carlson
set records as fox news makes history
in 2020 cable news ratings but the truth
is
there's been a massive decline hannity's
show
falling into last place for the 9 pm
time slot among what's called the key
demographic the 25
to 54 demographic hannity
stuck in that last place for two months
now now
it is true that hannity still has a ton
of viewers in the aggregate
but the declines have been significant
and part of the reason
is people are abandoning fox for further
loony right wing content on newsmax
and on oan i've been teasing that later
this week we're going to look in detail
at an incredible a focus group done by
frank luntz with trumpists and many of
them say
fox is too left we're now with newsmax
and
oan so part of hannity's decline is that
and there's sort of good and bad there
it's good that fewer people are watching
hannity
but it's bad that lots of them are
watching something even crazier
instead others have abandoned
hannity and they started to in december
when it became clear that all of
hannity's commentary
about how trump is just about to
overturn the results any day now
this is the path mr mayor rudy tell us
what's the pa
once it became clear that wasn't going
to happen there were some i guess you
would call them deflated trumpets who
also abandoned
and it's also relevant to think about
the untold damage that hannity did
throughout trump's presidency and one of
the reasons trump didn't face the same
fate as richard nixon
is there's a far more radical republican
party today
but another reason that trump didn't
face richard nixon's fate
is the right-wing media apparatus that's
so robust and powerful in the 21st
century that didn't exist
in the 1970s during richard nixon's
watergate scandal so
this is funny because i mean listen
it's funny because it's funny but it's
also
interesting because there are real
questions about what right-wing media
will look like during the next
for example two years the first two
years of joe biden's presidency and what
will be the lead-up to the 2022
midterm elections something else that's
important
the size of the pie for radical
right-wing propaganda
is not getting any bigger right now so
at the beginning of trump's uh
candidacy and presidency trump brought
in
a lot of people who were never into
politics that grew the pie for
right-wing media
people who never paid attention to
politics started to
fox was after being against trump early
in the republican primary of 2016
eventually supported trump and all of
this new audience people who never
watched the news before
were watching fox and newsmax was able
to get a little bit of it oan was able
to get a little bit of it
um but now as of 2020
the demand for radical right
disinformation propaganda it's not
growing in the aggregate
which means that fox news has to sort of
split its audience
with oan and with newsmax so right now
when newsmax grows
some portion of that growth is coming at
the expense of fox news
when oan grows some portion of that
growth is coming at the expense of fox
news
and it's more zero-sum than it's been in
a very long time it's not completely
zero-sum
but that's also a factor there will no
doubt
be an impact to fox news
from the reality that newsmax and oan
have bigger
platforms than ever who does fox news
need to appeal to now
they already have the oldest audience
and those folks will mostly stay with
fox news rather than going to oan
and newsmax the people that they need to
appeal to
are the 25 to 54 key demographic who
if you're 25 to 54 and you're watching
fox
and you're not pleased with them because
they're not right wing enough
and you bailed to fox to oan or newsmax
how does fox news win you back i don't
know the answer to that
i don't have an answer and quite frankly
i don't care it's for fox news to figure
out but it will be
interesting to follow now one other note
about the size of the pie
contrast this with independent left-wing
online media
independent left-wing online media has
been growing for two reasons over the
last several years yes
part of it is being in opposition to
trump the other part of it is that the
pie is growing and what i mean by that
is there are more and more people
who look for political content on
youtube
so when i get a new viewer i'm not
likely to be taking it from tyt
or from sam cedar or others it's more
likely that someone is now
getting their analysis on youtube
instead of
from legacy corporate media that's a
very different dynamic and i expect that
that's going to continue
we now have the absolute final numbers
for not only donald trump but melania
trump we are turning the page we are
starting a new era it is the joe biden
era
and what is an unfortunate irreversible
reality now that trump is done
is that donald trump has exited as the
least
popular president in history for as long
as there has been polling
and melania trump not to be outdone
is the least popular first lady in the
history
of the u.s for as long as there has been
polling
i gave you the numbers yesterday
according to pew research
trump's uh approval bottomed out at 29
percent yesterday
uh on gallup trump bottomed out at 34
but we now have the presidency wide
numbers trump's average approval
throughout his presidency
is 41 percent that is the least
popular president in the history
of the polling era trump also the only
president
never to at any time in the gallup
tracking survey
uh have 50 approval so trump
never hit 50 averaged 41
a low of any president in history and
going out at 34
the lowest of his entire presidency now
strictly speaking it's an appeal to
authority to say that a president's
popularity tells us if they were a good
or a bad president that's not what i'm
doing
i'm not saying trump was good or bad on
the basis of his approval
i am merely telling you that the guy
obsessed with good marks and popularity
and feeding his ego and being well liked
is the least well-liked president
in the history of the united states
during the polling era
similarly melania trump leaving the
white house
with the worst popularity rating
for any first lady at the end of her
term
in polling history cnn ssrs
has trump at 42 to 47.
um first ladies are just popular you
might say well 42 is not that bad
first ladies often have 60 or even 70
percent
uh popularity um
it's it's really something else and to
be to be perfectly frank
melania was barely a first lady she
didn't do and didn't appear um at
many of the things and in many of the
places that first ladies traditionally
have appeared at
she was a complete and total non-factor
it seems pretty clear she wanted nothing
to do with this presidency and it seems
pretty clear
at least from time to time it wasn't
clear she wanted much to do
with donald trump so we're really
closing the book on this
in a way that it's really not sad for me
the sad part is that their approval is
even as high as it is as i've said
before
their approval ratings should be
dramatically lower
but as uh as donald trump famously said
it is
what it is and trump will go into
history as the least popular president
in the history of the united states we
have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
here's something interesting there's
this uh trumpy right winger
troy york who's been calling into the
show for years
and this is sort of like a last salvo
from troy york as donald trump is done
and joe biden becomes president very
confused
maybe sort of dejected and just
spreading a lot of disinformation let's
listen to a little bit of it okay
take a listen to this yeah why do you
keep saying that
uh red states are the leeches and blue
states pay into more
what what well because that's true
talking about
blue states cost more with the pension
costs
okay so that see then now that blue
states cost more with pension costs
that has nothing to do with what i was
talking about the the frame here is
that if there were to be a civil war or
a secession
now unlike during the civil war
things are less clearly defined because
cities are overwhelmingly left whereas
rural areas are overwhelmingly right but
that if you can come up with a sort of
traditional blue state red state split
the country that would be made up of
american red states would be completely
unsustainable financially because as we
know
when it comes to federal funds paid in
by states or paid out two states
the blue states subsidized the red
states this has nothing to do with
state pensions the the cost for the
storing and locking up criminals um
the cost of big government why do you
keep saying that
the cost of big government yeah it
doesn't really sound like troy york
knows what he's talking about
red states are more sustainable they can
actually
take care of themselves produce food
and and again all of that is very wrong
i mean food is an interesting one
there's no doubt that many red and
purple states are big
food producers but you need only look at
the top food producers of the country to
see that
california produces twice as much food
as
any other state and then if you look at
the top 10
there's a bunch of purple and blue
states there you've got california
minnesota and illinois are top food
growers
wisconsin is a top food grower so yeah
sure
many red states produce a lot of food
but
it is not at all clear that uh that they
produce more than the blue state it
on every one of these things troy is
just wrong
boostings are the ones that are
constantly in debt
very much untrue and are mismanaged and
are not financially feasible yeah i mean
it's that so that's literally the
opposite of the truth as we've
we've looked at many times um there are
many more red states that without being
on federal welfare essentially money
from the federal government
there are many blue states that would be
sustainable there are very few red
states that would
and i don't know that the facts really
matter to a lot of these folks and
that's why tomorrow
we will be going through in detail or
friday it depends if i have time
uh a very interesting right-wing focus
group
with trump voters done by frank luntz
we have a fantastic bonus show today and
it's inauguration day it may already
have happened by the time you listen to
today's show
tomorrow full wall-to-wall coverage
of the joe biden inauguration of the
trumpian right-wing meltdown
of the future of joe biden's day one
priorities yes we will be covering them
and so much more get instant access
to the david pakman show membership
program and today's great bonus show
by signing up at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with any time over
phone or video chat you don't need
insurance it's only ninety nine dollars
a month with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman